let's go next to mark from Los Angeles
Mark welcome you guys are getting a
crazy Heat Wave right
oh boy mark from Los Angeles you were on
the air welcome Mark hello hello yes
oh hey hi hi sorry I um freaked out for
a second there with the
um yeah uh well uh I wanted to
compliment you because I
thought that your interview with the uh
was the uh I think was a candidate
um The Conspiracy Theory guy Mike
cargile
that was amazing it was crazy
it was I was like wow I don't know if
you saw Mark but Mike pillow was so
triggered by that interview that he sent
dozens of messages on Facebook in the
comments to that interview to my viewers
and to me
he probably related to the uh the ideas
and thought that this man this clearly a
very rational thing yes exactly I'm
fairly smeared by you right
um so uh speaking of conspiracy theories
I was wondering have you heard of birds
aren't real yes absolutely
um have you ever thought of interviewing
those guys there's no hilarious I mean
it's it's satire and we don't you know
the couple times we've done satirical
interviews on the show
they don't go well because half the
audience doesn't get that it's satire
and then the other half does and thinks
it's not really that interesting so
that's why we usually don't do the
satire interviews I did interview what's
the name of the candidate who puts the
boot on his head and Promises people
free ponies you know who I'm talking
about
hold on candidate free pony boot on head
what's the guy's name
um okay hold on here it is his name is
um Vermin Supreme I interviewed him and
like he says it's not satirical but like
if it's not satirical then he's nuts
yeah I don't know it just doesn't seem
to fit the show
okay okay this is just like the funny
thing is I you know I don't know if you
saw the 60 Minutes uh interview that was
really great no
um yeah they got covered on 60 Minutes
which is a big big uh step for them but
that's huge yeah yeah yeah
um they um I I when I saw this I was
like I have to have a shirt right
I must have shirt and so I put the shirt
on and I work with a lot of people who
some of them have conspiracy theories
and literally I'm going and they're
reading it like birds aren't real and
they ask and I'm telling them yeah you
know Birds aren't real if you notice
like the left wing and the right wing
you know and presidents speak to people
to tweet and they land on power lines
those power lines are just recharging
stations for all the birds and right
right people believe it it's hard well
Mark it sounds like quite a party uh but
we'll look into that for sure
um you've used the term
um and I love it uh
uh what is it uh it's not out of a
cannon before yeah this person shot out
of the cannon where do you get that from
it sounds like something like a parent
would say about a child or something
like that you know I think I got it from
Howard Stern
really I for some reason I feel like I
haven't listened to him for years but I
feel like it's something he would
sometimes say when you know someone
would come in like elegant Elliot often
and he he'd be shot out of a cannon
okay okay yeah I get it I get it because
it just to me it sounds like something
like apparently you've come in here from
school shot out of a can and calm down
yeah well listen Mark your shot out of a
cannon and I'm up against the brake so
I'm Gonna Let You Go okay all right have
a good one thank you so much I love your
show all right thanks Mark Mark from La
we're gonna take a quick break and then
go right back to the phones if you're
holding don't hang up because there will
be more opportunities to chat in just a
moment